Herzlich Wilkommen in Wels!
Panzerbataillon 14.
Ich werde die Herrschaften jetzt einmal aufwecken.
TAGWA...
Offensichtlich bin ich zu spät.
Hallo Robert.
Ich habe dir einen Panzeroverall mitgebracht, den schnell anziehen und dann kann es schon los gehen.
Na dann.
Guten Morgen.
Wir werden nicht allzu viel Zeit verlieren
und werden uns gleich unser Hauptgerät,
den Leopard 2A4, anschauen.
Dazu setze den Panzerhelm auf und dann sitzen wir auf.
Einmal rauf und bist schon oben, sehr gut.
Hier ist dein Platz mit der Ladeschütze, das ist mein Platz, der Kommandant,
da drinnen habe ich den Richtschützen und vorne in der Wanne haben wir den Fahrer.
Ich würde sagen wir fahren einmal zum Ausbildungszentrum.
Die Panzerstreitkräfte beim österreichischen Bundesheer, was muss ich wissen?
Es gibt ein Panzerbataillon, das ist das Panzerbataillon 14.
Wir verfügen insgesamt über 56 Kampfpanzer Leopard 2A4, wie wir mit einem hier Fahren.
Der Leopard ist noch immer der standard Kampfpanzer in Europa.
Wir haben 1500 PS, eine Kanone mit 120 mm, Einsatzschussweiten von 2000-2500 m,
wir bewegen uns im Gelände bis zu 80 km/h schnell und das voll stabilisiert.
Wenn ich jetzt davon träume Panzerfahrerin oder Panzerfahrer zu werden,
ich nehme an das geht für Frauen wie für Männer
Natürlich, wir haben genauso Frauen.
Was sind da die Ausbildungsschritte?
Eine Tauglichkeit von 5+, dann kann man bei uns alles werden, einrücken bei Panzerbataillon 14,
man kann als Grundwehrdiener Panzerfahrer, Richtschütze oder Ladeschütze werden.
Und als Kaderpräsenzsoldat sind die selben Funktionen möglich.
Wer bleiben will kann zum Panzerkommandanten oder Panzerzugskommandanten aufsteigen.
Jeder beim Bundesheer ist immer ganz besonders stolz auf seine Waffengattung, was macht die Panzerfahrer so stolz?
Wir sind das schwere, mechanisierte Rückrad der militärischen Landesverteidigung.
Wir schauen, dass wir alle anderen Waffengattungen mit unseren Hauptwaffensystem unterstützen.
Nehmen wir einmal an, dass du mir den Kommandantenposten nicht geben willst,
aber wie wäre es mit Panzerfahrer?
Da brauchen Sie natürlich ein wenig Ausbildung davor.
So Robert, ich darf dir jetzt vorstellen den
Oberleutnant Blaha, den Kommandanten unserer KPE.
Willkommen im Ausbildungszentrum, in der sogenannten AAT Ausbildungsanlage Turm.
Ich schlage vor, du gehst jetzt einfach als
Ladeschütze auf deinen Platz.
Mit wucht hinein.
Damit die Kanone in Feuerstellung geht, drückst du auf Hauptwaffe sicher.
Feuer.
Robert du hast dich nicht schlecht geschlagen, was sagst du wenn ich dich jetzt Panzerfahren lasse.
Bitte, endlich!
Das ist der Fahrlehrer, der wird dich einweisen.
Ich bitte dich einfach einmal hinein zu gehen.
Das ist ja cool.
Sehr gut.
Ich bin bereit.
Die Simulationsausbildung ist zu ende, wir können hinaus fahren.
Fahren wir.
Ich bin da.
Falschen Panzer erwischt.
Los gehts, nein?
Ok, versteh schon.
Alle von 01, Motor start, wir rücken ab,
Reihenfolge 1, 0, dahinter 12, Trennung, Fahrschulpanzer Übungsfahrt beginnen.
Ende.
Das war nicht schlecht, du hast gelernt einen Panzer zu bewegen.
Wir haben hier rechts einen Parkour für dich abgesteckt, den darfst du jetzt Probeweise abfahren.
Wäre ich noch einmal 2,3 Jahre jünger, also 18, dann hätte ich meine Einheit gefunden.
Was ich heute alles erlebt habe war schon
echt irre.
Total verantwortungsvolle, coole Leute, extrem gut ausgebildet, die einen unglaublichen Job machen
und das nicht nur wirklich gut, sondern Preisgekrönt gut.
Als Einheit des Jahres beim österreichischen
Bundesheer.
Und das ist echt speziell, das ist nämlich
ein internationaler Preis, welcher?
Das ist die Strong Europe Tank Challenge.
Wow, ihr wart die Allerbesten.
Herzliche Gratulation. Danke, dass ich dabe sein hab dürfen.
Danke, für dich hab ich noch kurz etwas,
unsere Badge und eine kleine Aufgabe die wir uns noch anschauen.
Eine Challenge noch?
Eine Challenge.
Sowas für mich?
Ja.
Ok, da bin ich dabei, gehen wir.
Das ist also der besondere Job für mich,
speziell für mich.